ready to drink the kool-aid now growing
up my mother wouldn't let me have it
it's sugar water awesome to cavities
yeah can't wait huh
I love the Elton John reference in my
childhood I don't remember the kool-aid
get partying with so many awesome
animals this tastes more just like
regular a fruit punch yeah I think it's
like do you hear it it's got all these
berries on it but we don't know much
berry like really tastes like um
is that good for Sam that's good alright
um I'm excited about this one mainly
because it's named after like good
dinosaur like pick lemonade there's no
fruit in this at all hey we're rolling
sound in here excuse me we're all sound
what happened I don't know I think up
because something else
but it is a strong Jolly Rancher smell
it's a tropical blast he's like I
definitely go summertime oh yeah what is
going on here guys
oh no I'm sorry guys this is ridiculous
we're just gonna have to do this another
time or something just I can't the hell
oh hello
do you see that yeah hello
what are you doing what was come on Ben
let's just go
hello it's just so sad what's happening
over there oh yeah
hmm that you don't know the half